I
so I think it's a speedo it was the
speeder yeah nothing - probably yeah
that definitely sold steel they thought
that was really awesome so they said
who's this sexy guy in the speedo
holding little alligator we need him now
yes so and they told me these jackass
guys are looking for you they want to do
something with you and they go people to
him they really really dumb guys I heard
yeah these guys are really bad
they really dum-dum I'm telling you them
and eventually I ran into him and we
yeah first day out steve-o gets ran over
by an airboat and he puts a warm up his
nose
Johnny knocks once a good bit by rattle
sink on purpose you know years later I
showed him my hand I hey this is why I
didn't want you to get bit by rattle
sink you understand I told him that
that's from a rattlesnake yes oh my god
yeah I know it's on your Instagram you a
lot of your photo you put your hand out
to show your finger it's a signature
mark and make sure it's it's not it's
not an impostor it's the right guy you
know everybody knows that lost a finger
to rattlesnake okay this is it's made it
- it's kind of like a joke man there's
no fake Manny Puig you can't impersonate
steve-o steve-o took a picture of it
first thing when he saw it and send it
to Jeff Tremaine you was laughing look
at this guy sure but I got bit by a
rattlesnake in high school I was 17
years old
egg me rattler what were you doing
picking it up the same way that I got
bit by western diamondback the same
style repeat the whole thing with the
bigger rattle sync and that one I said I
looked at myself thinking I really
messed up this time where was this at
Texas Tech so at 15 you're already like
catching animals and doing all that
stuff high school levels and catching
large alligators by hand I was picking
up venomous snakes I was doing it all
that kind of stuff spearfishing what
made you want to do this at such a young
age what got you into it was there
something that inspired you to do this
sir
I think I saw too many like Tarzan
movies
see hunt yeah you know Lloyd Bridges Oh
Jungle Jim underwater of fighting with
alligators all these different that's
all these different aquatic and you know
well life guys and all that stuff and I
really you know got me inspired Wow
so what happened when you got bit when
you were young what do you have to do
after you got bit you just do the
hospital or what I ended up in the
hospital my friends started tell me you
better I think oh well what are we
supposed to do you know and you know you
were watching too many movies and I go
was supposed to get drunk or something
like that and this is the guide the
fringe all looking at me kind of funny
like that dude I think we better take
you to a hospital
let's just take it home and then when I
got the hospital I was worried about how
much it was gonna cost ya and it told me
you want to keep that hand
you better lay down there and let us get
to work on you what do they have to do
to you to get rid of the venom or before
they imitate the anti-venom that's what
they did in Tibet right right
anti-venom and then they were back then
they would try to set the poison idea
with a suction cup now later on they
don't do it anymore
no they just take it to a hospital and
they put you on an anti-venom they hold
your arm up high you know to keep the
swelling down
yeah now the amount of venom I grabbed
that rattle synced by the neck and he
made a half a turn on me got both things
in a one finger and you know I held him
and I picked him up and I told the
producer it got me and he goes no no I
didn't it did so it was like oh no
everybody's like froze and I think buck
medley goes let's go to the hospital
does acai was with it for many dice it's
let's go like right now so we got in a
car we're going about 110 miles an hour
oh wait oh Hospital we're about this was
for the recent bite yeah for the last
one that I was there's a Diamondback you
said western diamondback about six feet
long it was a monster
where were you Texas in Texas - yeah
it's like I don't really want to pick up
many more venomous snakes that's the
second one that was just I'm still
recuperating ten years later what was
going through your mind when that
happened like what were you thinking
what did you what were you trying to do
like were you you did you liked I uh no
I didn't do they didn't tie anything to
it no turning it's really like bummed
out it's almost like you got in a flat
tire in the middle of nowhere it's just
a really yeah you know depressing
feeling yeah usually like woozy from it
and no I don't feel woozy or anything I
just felt tremendous pain and no time it
just got do it I knew was I knew what I
was into I knew I was gonna be horrific
yeah
then it was so bad I could feel the
venom I was praying the whole way
praying they got the whole Hospital I'm
a Christian so I was praying you know
God keep me around right a little bit
longer for more time yeah this is I says
I felt like I wasn't gonna make it
really really no sense yeah Hospital
when I got in there they were taking her
time in the hospital warming up the core
fat that's what they injected and I said
well we're gonna I said you getting
warmed up yet how long had it been bad
time you out of the hospital about 45
minutes and I'm like I need about
55-gallon drum or that stuff you got
there yeah I said this snake was
enormous I have a ton of venom in me and
if you guys don't put a lot of this
stuff in me the thing is gonna really
mess me up I told him that Oh taking the
time and you're thinking hurry the hell
you got to go like this and warm it up
with their hands the core fat because
it's kept and like frozen right to
preserve it so I was like man they
should have had it ready before I got
here we called it in
it happens in Texas so often they don't
care there were three people in the
hospital that they counting me that were
bit by rattle sink really no way yeah
that side cuz yeah it's no big deal over
there you know the guy had a finger it
was all black like mine was getting and
he goes he told my friend oh yeah I'm
probably lose that finger and sure
enough they told well looks like your
finger my make it I went to back home to
Miami a few weeks later I couldn't they
let me out after four days I couldn't
even get inside an airplane to go home I
stayed in bug medleys house laying in a
bed there for two weeks
yeah I could hardly do anything I
couldn't pick up a cup of coffee with
that hand and the pain was tremendous
and when I got home my in-law took me to
a hospital and the doctor said you got
to stay here the fingers gonna come off
oh okay let's get it off right now then
oh yes just the finger was in like
tremendous pain it wasn't your whole
body oh well the hand just a hand the
arm the swelling went all the way up my
arm all the way to like my side of my
body I had swollen everywhere you know
it was like a balloon I mean
tremendously I mean puffed up right but
when you were on the way to the hospital
when they were driving a hundred miles
an hour trying to get you there like
where you just sitting were you holding
your arm up did you
anything specific to try to hopefully
like stop the venom from spreading into
your body they had some frozen chicken
at picked over and I put my hand on the
frozen chicken and I found out later
they not even supposed to do that oh
that wasn't that was the wrong thing to
do also you're not supposed to get it
you're not supposed to do anything but
go to the hospital yeah as fast as you
can and you know try to relax I was
relaxed I wasn't yeah I wasn't freaking
out I wasn't agitated I was more like
bummed out
yeah right okay you know I've been
through some stuff I mean I the Outdoor
Channel I had that rattlesnake bite I
also got bit by an alligator in the back
the only time I've ever been bitten by
an alligator and my entire life of
messing with alligators he snuck up
behind me and bit me when I wasn't
looking so he grabbed the wetsuit and
peeled off my back so he was not able to
get a good grip on me so again the good
Lord saved me from that one it was a 10
foot of snow coming from behind in a
canal I was swimming down I thought my
friend the Indian guy that hit me
airboat you know what I heard an herbal
did he just run me over what's going on
here in the boat what was like 50 yards
behind and when the alligator and I
could hear the airboat coming the
alligator didn't care unless just come
out of cover and got me from behind I
was too lazy to look behind me and then
I faced him off I chased him and harass
him so he wouldn't affect me again and
then I don't know what was wrong with me
I got in the airboat I say well I'm able
to get an airboat I peel the wetsuit
back and head toward let me know I told
everybody what's wrong with my back let
me know yeah and he goes wasn't better
all 12 scratches that's it that's it
I was gonna look I gotta go to shore and
put a bottle of bleach on it like right
now that's what I said bleach yeah it
kills all the bacteria holy [ __ ] that's
pretty straight bleach straight bleach a
rattlesnake I mean an alligator yeah can
kill you just like a rattle sink with a
bacteria and it smell okay oh really
even if he survived his bite he can
right
[Laughter]